bueno como habéis indicado en realidad
colonia es la principal puerta de salida
de los ucranianos que quieren seguir con
sus vidas del conflicto y huir de la
guerra y esto es precisamente donde
estamos uno de los principales puntos
calientes es el pueblo de shiming que
está nada apenas de 20 km de la frontera
y en esta ocasión sí que es verdad con
los polacos están volcando están
haciendo muchos esfuerzos dando en
muchas formaciones para que los
ucranianos que llegan a partir que
generalmente han estado entre 32 o un
día cruzando la frontera pues puedan
encontrar ropa agua caliente como veis
ahí hay un puesto de ropa de todos
nacimos de ropa también aquí tenemos
comida hay también unas tiendas de
campaña con calefacción para aquellos
que llegan fríos puedan pasar la noche
siguiente alentador y también hay todo
tipo de servicios como por ejemplo
traducción y se está ayudando a
encontrar si no hay inversiones libres
para mí se pone a su disposición
bueno pues otro tipo de albert esos
sitios no pueda pasar la noche y luego
las esperas son más emocionantes son los
polacos que están viviendo aquí con
pancartas
están cartas mías que escriben que están
dispuestos a presionar ubicación de su
casa que están dispuestas a trabajar en
las familias o incluso a llegarles en
coche a cualquier otro punto de colonia
para poder ayudarles nosotros estamos
hablando perdidos con los platos que
tienen aquí a prestar ayuda a los
victorianos que llegan autobuses y les
preguntamos bueno pero de dónde sale
toda esta voluntad para para dar esta
protección a los super bien nos decían
que eran esta guerra de planeo les
recuerda mucho a cuando en la segunda
guerra mundial también polonia fue
aprendida con una de sus vecinos